believe it or not the two-year
anniversary of the pandemic is this
march and over the course of the past
two years few industries have struggled
as much as the restaurant industry with
the early quarantine period keeping
people at home many eateries shuttered
for good last year the restaurant
revitalization fund created a pool of
28.6 billion dollars in grants for
independent restaurants but after the
surge of the omicron variant many
restaurant operators are once again
worried about what lies ahead in the
future now here to talk with us more
about the state of the restaurant
industry is tom colicchio he's the owner
of crafted hospitality and founding
member of the independent restaurant
coalition that's a trade group started
by independent restaurants and chefs
during the covert 19 pandemic tom
welcome to quick take
thanks for having me
well tom we mentioned it just in the
intro here that the restaurant industry
is actually the one of the
worst hit by the pandemic but there was
some relief that was provided in that
restaurant revitalization fund but the
problem was that it didn't reach all of
the businesses that needed it and that's
really the argument that's being put
forward on the hill when there are
negotiations to bring about more funding
just how significant is this funding to
the restaurant industry
right well that's that's correct there
was a 28.6 billion dollars that went out
to restaurants but that it only actually
the grants were only made to about
one-third of the restaurants that
applied there were over 300 000
restaurants that applied and roughly 100
000 actually received some relief and so
we're about 40 billion dollars short and
what it does is it creates a real sort
of uh you know those that have it those
that don't situation for restaurants
those that receive money uh they are
able to get their bills paid keep their
staff together and those that didn't
receive money are struggling uh we're
hearing stories of restauranteurs and
chefs that are uh going you know into
their personal
you know finances and writing checks to
their staff um maxing out on credit
cards and things like that uh personally
for me i'm i'm uh in debt to my
landlords uh uh to a pretty significant
sum at this point and so it's it's been
tough um but uh you know we're getting
close uh
uh we're looking for a package that not
only includes restaurants but also
stages um uh to to help the restaurants
and stages that haven't received funding
yet uh so we can all level out the
playing field
and you know things were
starting to look better but omicron came
and really uh you know shut everything
down again uh even though the government
hasn't forced us to shut down uh we were
unable to staff restaurants and so it's
been tough that and the fact that so
many people are still nervous about
going out um and eating so we're looking
at a tough winter ahead but hopefully uh
you know we can get something done here
and tom you mentioned the omicron
variant which has clearly made things go
from bad to worse but there are signs
now at least in new york that some of
those cases now may be peaking so how
long do you think it will take for the
restaurant industry to get back on its
feet again
it's still going to take some time yes
it's starting to peak but we're still at
over 10 in new york um last year when we
were 10 uh we were told not to go out so
it's it's still uh pretty prominent um
also we're looking at historically the
worst two months in the restaurant
industry um so i don't think we're gonna
be back on track until maybe valentine's
day um but even then uh we're you know
there are there are restaurants that are
hanging on by a thread at this point and
uh you know listen i'm in a position
where i've been in business long enough
i can negotiate with my landlords
there's a lot of small mom and pops or
restaurants that have been in business
for a couple years they don't they don't
have that that kind of um uh you know
that opportunity and that quite frankly
privilege that that i have and so those
are the restaurants that are really
struggling right now and so we need we
need help um and yes what's at stake
here
it's not just at individual restaurants
it's communities that rely on that
restaurant it's the 15 million
restaurant workers that work at
independent restaurants it's the farmers
and fishermen that supply us it's the
electricians and plumbers that service
our restaurants so we're looking at a
pretty large ecosystem of of uh of
people at that independent restaurant
support and that's that's really at
stake here you know plus we're also you
know you look at the safety of different
communities restaurants um you know
we're open late our lights are on on
late it keeps neighborhoods safe and
with restaurants going dark um i suspect
that we're going to see you know crime
uh start to pick up in some of these
neighborhoods as well so there's a whole
host of reasons why uh we should get
this done
not just a straight economic incentive
for the restaurants but there's also a
whole
stake here and tom jumping in here you
mentioned the workers and the
difficulties there for them but also
we're dealing with a labor shortage in
this industry where it is a real
struggle to hire workers and to keep
them and we've had to uh increase wages
really to keep them but do you think uh
that
what more needs to be done to bring
workers back would you think a lot of
them are actually just reconsidering
their careers all together right now
when you talk to a lot of the staff
yeah i think there's a few things i
think some have reconsidered and when
they were laid off uh you know they
found jobs elsewhere a lot of people
have become entrepreneurs and are
starting their own businesses they had a
side hustle that turned into a real
business
also wages are going up and actually i
think that's a good thing um that's also
putting a lot of stress on restaurants
but i think ultimately that's that's
good but also keep in mind with that
restaurant workers that maybe work two
jobs or a job and a half now they're
getting by on one job and they're making
enough money and so there's there's
fewer people in the workplace because of
that um there's a whole host of reasons
why why it's difficult out there and i
don't think any one of them are because
people are lazy i think people are are
working we're at near full employment
right now
um and yet there are a lot of people who
are out of the workforce listen there
are a lot of people sitting home you
know
day trading you know cryptocurrency i
you know there's a lot of things that
people are doing right now um other than
coming into work but uh um
i think
uh
that problem will work itself out as
well tommy you mentioned some of the
specific challenges that you yourself
had faced one of those who said well
rents and of course you're having to pay
utilities higher wages so how did you uh
navigate this in terms of keeping the
costs low
well you you really can i mean we we did
find that that perhaps we can run the
restaurants with fewer people
when the restaurants were shut down i
was doing a delivery box business but we
were shipping all across the country um
you know 200 to 250 boxes at a time in
fact right now
we have a super bowl box that we are
selling
it's a little more difficult to do now
the restaurants open but when
restaurants were closed i turned my
entire dining room into a shipping
department and you know you get by you
do whatever you can
but we're also finding that we can we
can run the restaurant with fewer people
costs are going up again i'm lucky
enough where there's some elasticity
in my my concept that i can actually
raise prices where again some of those
neighborhood restaurants smaller
restaurants they can't do that so
they're they're struggling with eating
the cost of
increased prices for meat dairy fish
pretty much everything and so uh but i
was able to raise prices uh you know
we'll see
you know i i may lose some customers
because of that but i you know i'm an
upscale restaurant where my my my
uh clients can afford that but other
other restaurants aren't in the same
position do you think there are any
benefits that you could find to opening
a restaurant right now in this
environment
the only advantage right now is because
there are a lot of shuttered restaurants
there's a lot of spaces available uh
landlords are are you know
a little more generous when it comes to
tenant improvements or ti's of the money
that they'll they'll put in for the
restaurants to be there plus there are a
lot of restaurants that are built out so
now you can go and pick up a restaurant
that is built out maybe do some some
cosmetic upgrades to it and get a
restaurant going um but uh you know
there's something about that doesn't
doesn't feel great um
but that that's really about it i i
can't think of any other silver lining
here um you know unfortunately uh you
know we're hearing stories of a lot of
customers that are unruly they're
frustrated they want to come out and
because we're short staffed maybe
service is slow and there's there's
frustration there so it's so we got we
have a long way to go
um
you know i i don't i don't see a whole
lot of silver lining except
the work that we did with the
independent restaurant coalition where
you had a a group of about 150 200 of us
across the country that came together
and are still working really really hard
to make sure that our government uh you
know hears us loud and clear that we
still need help and so it was great that
we were able to do that and we were able
to to get some funding for our industry
but we still have a long way to go yep
and tom quickly i just want to pivot to
uh one quick question on nfts here
because i know you are experimenting
with a pizza nft so how is that going
and how do you think uh you know the the
food and beverage industry how do they
play in that space
well it's not just a pizza nft because
you know nfts the average person needs
to understand that they moved really far
past just a piece of artwork um that you
know that was actually cool because
artists were able to you know bypass the
gallery system create art that they were
able to sell to the public and not only
do they get a you know that sale from
the initial minting but they were able
to get any you know additional money on
all secondary sales so that was great
for the artist that was the early stages
and this is all moving very quickly
nowadays it's all about utility and so
it's what you can create so what we're
really doing with our pizza it's not so
much about pizza but it's about creating
a community of either chefs
restauranteurs plus people who just love
food and so if you go to our discord
there's a lot of discussions we actually
had a pizza contest where we judge the
pizza contest there's a there's a lot of
discussions about restaurants and it's
broken into various cities and so people
are communicating with each other so
it's really about creating that
community and then what utility does
that nft hold um and so for us we're
working on that and that could be
discounts for for uh uh kitchen
equipment at home and things like that
or you know um
appliances uh um it could be uh uh you
know cooking classes uh via zoom for any
of the nft holders um there is a a
another restaurant nft um that might my
friend and chef josh capon has started
where the nft is actually the the pass
the key for a private restaurant
so there's a lot that's going to happen
but really what this is is this is a an
entree into web30
and
you know the way i i i like it is if you
think about a cell phone the old cell
phones the first generation of cell
phones these big bulky things that we
kind of laugh at now
and nowadays we have a smartphone that
has more computing power than the
computers that send the apollo mission
to the moon and so what is 3.0 going to
look like in terms of what we can do so
it's going to be some simple stuff where
instead of having a a a two-dimensional
web page you're gonna have a
three-dimensional web page that you're
gonna be able to walk through and
actually see the restaurant meet some of
the people but ultimately i think you
know down the road five six years from
now i'm gonna send you a box of food and
you're gonna be able to put on some you
know vr glasses and be in my restaurant
eating it um so you think about a brand
extension there but we don't even know
the possibilities of web 3 on what's
going to happen right now and so for me
nfts are just entree into that space the
technology is moving very very quickly
and uh it's gonna be an exciting next
next five years as the you know web 30
metaverse is is built out
yeah tom much more to watch in that
space there thank you so much for
joining us we love getting your insights
and really hoping things pick up in the
industry that was tom colicchio there
the founding member of the independent
restaurant coalition thank you for
joining us